the nominations for the 54th annual cma
awards are officially in
and miranda lambert and carrie underwood
are both up for entertainer of the year
luke combs and carly pierce announced
several of the leading categories live
from the iconic grand ole opry where it
was revealed that not one
but two solo women are up for the
night's top prize which
actually hasn't happened since 1979.
these are the nominees for cma
entertainer of the year eric church
miranda lambert carrie underwood
keith urban and luke combs
so of course carrie miranda are up
against eric church keith urban and
newcomer
luke combs which comes after garth
brooks recently decided to remove
himself from contention
after taking home entertainer of the
year seven
times i know it's so amazing so garth
won four times in the 90s and three
times within the last four years
including
last year in a press conference last
month the country superstar told
reporters
it's time for somebody else to hold that
award
so garth admitted that after his last
win he started to consider taking a step
back as many country fans were hoping
carrie would
finally win especially after her massive
tour
and fans will also remember miranda
openly campaigned for carrie to win
writing a lengthy post to twitter
reading in parts
she put out her first single in 2005 and
from then on
country music was changed for good that
iconic voice has been classing up our
stages
charts and televisions for a decade and
a half the voice
the legs the songs the brand the mom the
wife the jesus lover the blonde
bombshell that is carrie
she blows me away every time i hear her
sing
now the last time a female one
entertainer of the year
was back in 2000 so we can only hope
miranda or carrie will take it home this
year
miranda also tops the list with seven
noms making cma award history
as the first female artist to accumulate
a record-breaking
55 total career nod
is
meanwhile kelsey ballerini was among
those snubbed writing on twitter
last time this happened i wrote
homecoming queen the next day about the
feeling
something beautiful will undoubtedly
come from the current disappointment
nonetheless congratulations to my
friends and peers that got nominations
proud to be a part of the country family
always
kane brown who was also once again left
out of this year's nominations
was quick to make kelsey feel better
replying hold your head up
now the 2020 cma awards will take place
in nashville on november 11th
more details on the performers and this
year's hosts are expected to come
in the coming weeks so what do you think
about this year's nominations and who
are you surprised to see left
out sound off in the comments below